thanks to mubi for sponsoring this video
get your 30 day free trial at movie.com
thomasflight
i like chess and i find it interesting
and engaging so
i hope i'm not offending anyone when i
say that it is
not a cinematic game actually on one
level it mimics one of the most
cinematic things we portray on screen
two people
in conflict sitting down across from
each other
having a conversation but what i mean is
that the game itself
what's happening on the board is not
easily conveyed
visually it takes at least a moderate
knowledge of what is a pretty complex
game to understand the significance of
the individual moves and the position
of the pieces on the board and even if
you could expect
an audience to know what's going on on a
chessboard
portraying those moves clearly on screen
would be very visually
awkward and boring but queen's gambit
isn't really about games of chess
anyway the chess games simply set the
stage for dramatic conflict between
elizabeth harmon and her opponents and
beth's own
internal conflict with herself in the
second episode of queen's gamut there's
a climactic scene where very few words
are spoken
and yet there's drama conflict and a
story arc that we can clearly follow
since the filmmakers couldn't rely on
the action on the board
or dialogue to supply the drama they had
to create it entirely through physical
performance
cinematography editing and score
first let's look through the conflict
and the story that's established in the
scene
and then we can examine the techniques
used to create these story beats
visually
[Music]
the main conflict in the first half of
the scene is between beltick and beth's
emotional approaches to the game
harry beltik what's your name beth
harmon
beth is taking things very seriously and
is slightly unsure of things because
it's her first tournament beltic doesn't
see beth as a real threat
and is behaving overly casually arriving
late
after she's made the first move having
run down his
own clock
beth is put off by his casual demeanor
and becomes frustrated
when she's unable to make a move that
makes him
take the game more seriously
she tries to focus and get the upper
hand
but she's emotionally shaken when she's
unable to
be right back she excuses herself to the
bathroom where she takes
the drug she uses to enhance her
cognitive performance while playing
chess
when she returns she's more focused and
makes decisive moves
that give her the upper hand an
unsettled belt tick he's forced to play
more seriously but it's too late and
beth is able to win
the opening shot seems to establish beth
as having the upper hand over the
chessboard
the low angle makes her tower over the
board and she appears confidently angry
harry beltic's lateness is established
clearly through the empty seat the sound
of the ticking clock
beth's annoyance and the clock in the
background but when harry enters
so casually next cup of coffee he towers
over beth
the cinematography subtly indicates that
beth might have command of the board but
for now
harry has commanded the scene i think
the choice here not to shoot down on
beth for shadows her win
but the camera is still conveying the
temporary upper hand that harry has
by letting him loom even larger on
screen
harry beltic what's your name
beth harmon from here the drama is
defined through performance
actor harry melling shows us the
casualness and ease
of harry's first move and anja taylor
joy shows us how beth's annoyance and
anger at his lateness
melts into surprise that he's so
casually confident
her focus here as it's portrayed by
taylor joy seems to be on shaking
harry's attitude
and not on the game itself this is
portrayed through beth's glares at harry
but also through how the emphasis is
placed on him and not the board
in both the cinematography and the
editing for example this cut
into a close-up of his yawn especially
emphasizes where beth's focus lies
meanwhile you may notice that harry
barely acknowledges or
looks at beth he keeps his attention on
the board and continues to
quickly and casually respond to each of
her moves without dialogue the actor's
physical performances have to do a lot
of the heavy lifting
to convey the dramatic conflict look at
how taylor joy uses this quick glance to
convey how beth
is checking in with beltick to see if
his demeanor has been shaken
after a move or how her shoulders fall
subtly and disappointment
when he is able to respond to yet
another move quickly
and decisively this back and forth
continues for a while beginning to build
suspense in the scene
the cinematography and rhythm of the
editing at this point portrays
the characters as fairly evenly matched
they're framed equally
in the profile and over the shoulder
angles because most viewers won't be
able to tell by the board how the game
is progressing
this equality of framing helps convey
that neither player is decisively
winning the game
at this point and a break in
cinematography from the
over-the-shoulder angles to
this more straight-on shot as well as
from the faster back and forth editing
rhythm
to a longer hold on this shot combined
together with beth's change
in posture visually indicates a shift in
beth's thinking
and approach to the game she's trying to
focus
to find a move that will break harry's
casual
attitude this cutaway to the audience
and then back to beth in the same
position
helps signify that time is passing we
feel innately that she's probably been
mulling over this
move longer than we actually see her
think about it on screen
but even after all this concerted effort
harry's response
is so quick and casual that it doesn't
even warrant being shown on screen
instead the focus remains on beth's
mounting frustration
and when harry continues in this
attitude beth
for the first time starts to look
worried and her worry
develops into fear she might lose the
game
be right back beth heads to the bathroom
and takes the fictional tranquilizer
that she used to help
learn chess the shift in the scene and
the onset of the drug is marked by
the introduction of score
[Music]
score itself carries emotion in this
case the triumphant score signals to us
that
beth is now confident she'll be able to
win the game
but aside from that the score's presence
also works in contrast
against the absence of score so far to
indicate
a shift in the scene the moment in the
bathroom is composed as a single shot
which
contrasts the faster editing of most of
the rest of the scene
and it reflects the scene's opening shot
these longer shots help to create a
separation between best perspective when
she's on her
own and her perspective when she's
facing an opponent
the subtle downward movement of the
camera in this moment serves the dual
purpose
of revealing the ceiling where beth
visualizes the chess games
and making beth look larger and
therefore more dominant and confident
on the screen when we return to the
table it opens on harry's reaction and
through melling's performance we
see that he seems to be noticing
something significant
besides the score and the shifts and
performances
the other change you'll notice is the
shift in cinematography
the scene moves from the more
conventional over the shoulder shots
used
earlier to these more direct centered
and opposite
close-ups it gives the feeling that
beth's focus has narrowed
these super close-up shots of the board
also help indicate that her focus has
shifted
from harry's attitude to the board and
the game itself
the shallow depth of field and the
camera's tight focus on the pieces
conveys
beth's type focus on those pieces and
shifting her focus
and gaining the upper hand in the game
beth achieves her goal from the first
half of the scene
shaking harry's attitude and some of the
conflict of the scene is resolved
at this point even though someone not
familiar with chess might not be able to
know what's happening on the board
the position of the pieces on the board
does gain some symbolic significance
the game in this scene is a recreation
of a real game from 1955 played by
rasheed nesmetanov
and genre kasparian the specific game is
one that ends with white's queen
and black's king directly beside each
other part of the narrative conflict of
this scene
this episode and the show as a whole is
beth navigating a world that is
dominated by
men representing beth with the queen and
baltic with the king
allows the scene to end with the clear
symbolism
of the queen defeating the king
the scene has resolved its immediate
conflict of beth's confidence being
shaken by harry's casual attitude
but it leaves some unresolved conflict
to build suspense
for the rest of the show we're left with
the question
did beth win because of the effect of
the drug itself
or did the drugs simply restore her
confidence
so that she could win using her natural
ability
and we'll have to continue watching to
find out it's not the lack of dialogue
that makes this scene so great there's a
lot of great scenes with dialogue
throughout the show but when the
dialogue is stripped away it helps us
see clearly the elements of the show
that i think
make queen's gambit so great the writing
and plot are compelling but it's the
attention to detail to visually convey
the story in both the filmmaking and
performances
that really makes it shine
mubi is a hand curated online streaming
cinema they have a huge selection in
their
library and the now showing section
introduces a new film
every day with an explanation of why
it's worth your time
recently in the library i watched the
perverts guide to ideology directed by
sophie fines
this film is essentially a
feature-length video essay
sophie finds combines clips from films
and
other media and pop culture with the
philosophical and political musings of
slovenian philosopher slavoy zizek
whether or not you agree with xi jiax
politics it's a fascinating film
and a great example of the potential of
video essay on a larger scale
check out this film or any of the others
from mubi's selection of art house
independent and farn films when you sign
up for your extended 30-day free trial
by going to movie.com thomasflight
that's mubi.com
thomasflight i love mubi and i want to
thank them for their ongoing support of
my channel
thanks as well to my patrons for their
ongoing support if you enjoyed this
video i did a live stream of my editing
process
on my second channel check it out with
the link in the description and
subscribe to my second channel if you're
interested in future editing and q a
live streams
isis for protection